the american cup has a new and exciting
format a double elimination bracket how
do you feel about that
i really like the format because it
combines both classical and fast chess
so even if you lose one match you still
have another chance in rapid chess i
think it's an interesting format
you have double elimination so even
one mistake is not going to be so costly
i mean you can still recover so
i think it's going to be a lot of fun so
i think the format feels different
already right now and feels great feels
even like better because it's like you
have to work really hard but like you
have this match and if you win that much
you make a big step forward compared to
the us championship where it's like
every round matters the same way and
it's a really long event uh so this is
more like you know a short track instead
of a marathon
yeah the format is very interesting i've
never
definitely never played in this
exact format before i don't even know if
i
heard of this exact format before i
actually really like it it's not only
because it's novel but just um yeah i
think it's exciting and it brings in
more more exciting chess and also
there's no draw draw offers so i think
that will only help
make this a really interesting event
yeah i think the format it's really
interesting
everyone's probably
really looking forward to to get into
action i think especially when you have
these multiple time controls and also
you know the no extra 30 minutes we're
going to see a lot of time scrambles a
lot of time trouble no but i think it's
it's it's a good format and i know
uh this is very good for spectators and
uh for like for chess audience it's much
more
like fire on board and i think it's a
great idea uh but any case actually i
have don't fully understand the
the
format yet but i'm just focusing on one
game at a time um it's a very
interesting format pretty much
a lot of these matches will come down to
shorter time controls which will be very
interesting uh yeah it's new so we are i
guess we we all want to to see how it it
goes in practice but it it i'm pretty
sure it's uh it's going to be
interesting well i think if you ask 20
different players what formats they like
the most you get 20 answers and while
this format is not like exactly what i
would
come up with if i just could choose
perfectly myself it's about as close as
anything i've ever seen i like the
faster time format i think it's gonna be
like a very fast fast-paced exciting
tournament and i think the players will
enjoy it and i think the viewers should
enjoy it too yeah i like the idea double
elimination is used in a lot of esports
and chess is sort of not quite in that
category but sort of in that category so
it makes sense to try out this format
and i think it might
after this get adopted in some other
tournaments i really like the format
that the st louis chess club has come up
with the
double knockout
format right quite innovative actually
it makes a lot of sense from a chess
player's perspective the idea that um
you know even if you lose one match
you're still not out of the tournament
there's a second chance so i think
that's actually perfect double
elimination i have never played such
tournaments before and i when i saw the
regulation i was very excited about that
and i thought wow that's
that's amazing and i really wanted to
try it
i cannot say much because i don't have
any experience but after the tournament
i will let you know
[Music]